plutôt très habitants de KFS sont comme
moi les habitants de Kiev se réveillent
en vérifiant si leur chauffage a été
reconnecté dans mon appartement c'était
pas le cas je connais d'autres personnes
qui ont vu leur chauffage rallumé hier
soir c'est bien sûr la priorité pour les
habitants de Kiev le chauffage est
affecté par les pénuries électricité
pour diverses raisons et les gens
pensent qu'ils peuvent bien sûr
continuer sans électricité s'ils ont des
batteries s'ils ont d'autres solutions
beaucoup plus longtemps que sont
chauffage avec des températures qui
avoisine zéro comme vous avez dit ça
c'est la priorité mais les autorités
promettent de réinstaller le chauffage
rapidement pour l'électricité c'est
beaucoup moins sûr l'une des plus
grandes compagnies d'électricité sont
directeurs hier à annoncé à la
télévision que aujourd'hui il pensait
pouvoir fournir de l'électricité aux
habitants de la capitale
2 à 3 heures maximum avant de repasser
dans les jours qui viennent à un système
de coupure d'électricité un peu moins
fréquente mais même avant cette dernière
vague d'attaque on en était déjà à avoir
de l'électricité seulement la moitié du
temps dans la capitale d'autres régions
du crâne sont un peu moins affectés mais
tout de même
que la compagnie de distribution
d'électricité étatique indique en ce
moment ils sont en mesure de fournir
seulement la moitié des besoins du pays